walk the bridge of the hearts cap good
to be here Moses feel right inside your
bus man it's amazing out here man this
is a Canada's kind of become second home
for us we did 27 headlining shows here
last year you know through this country
so uh yeah I'm about to show you what
the fan base is out there now what's the
festival life like like how is it
different from doing like a tour like
growing tour that's what life's a lot
different you're first off like when
it's your own tour like wolf we'll set
out an October be our tour we know
exactly what to expect every day you
know we get know we getting a good
routine festival life it kind of breaks
up a little bit you know and every day
is a little bit different is the crowd
different yeah from place to place is
gonna be different the energy is gonna
be different we're like I say like when
we're doing our own tour we know that
every fan in there is to see us right so
these kind of things sometimes you're
not sure exactly what it's gonna be like
when you walk out not able to the time I
know what it's gonna be like but
sometimes you're throwing a little bit
of a curveball but in Canada I know what
it's gonna be like every time we walk I
walk out there how it's gonna be I'm
telling you that that your post
well I do I'm just letting you know that
I know who the people are excited to see
on there I'm just like a no that's good
that's kind of let you know man and
we're stoked like we're always like
Canada like I express all the time I
mean the Canadian fans for us that bents
it's been so special then we packed out
so many big rooms here and they they
just they're the people here is become
such a piece of my heart that's why I
spend so much time coming here like I
said we did 27 headlining shows last
year which I which I was told was the
most American artist has done in about
20 years so I mean it's uh
we're devoted to them and they're
devoted to us we love you here yeah
now one [ __ ] with this new song she's
mine yeah so no for like 36 hours what's
that now it's only been out for more
like 30 hours right now so is that a
nerve-wracking first 24 hours you're
gonna rock the shirt you know yeah I
mean I think there's a little bit of
anxiety there's a little bit excitement
you know it's all those things combined
into one because you know I write music
with them in mine too
so it's you're always hoping people
receive it the way they you know you had
it in your mind that was gonna happen
right are you like personally going on
like Twitter or Instagram like see what
people's yeah I do you know not not like
a whole lot but I'm definitely checking
up you know especially in that first 10
hour span like I just kind of want to
see how people reacting to the music you
know and this one might be the biggest
reaction I've ever seen with a song I'll
put up bigger than bigger than a pretty
girl truck last shot this is this has
been a big reaction the song for like 10
years yeah well I mean we tried to
record it for the Wild Ones record and
we just missed them are plain and simple
we didn't capture the magic of the song
in the studio we cut off the edges of it
it got too smooth it got too slick
it felt like everybody else and I never
want to make use it to sound like other
people yeah we know it's new it's gonna
be a hit I knew that the hit was there
what's the focus are you just me I just
it was just one stage and I even went
out when I pulled it back up eight years
later in the dressing room and I'm
playing it on my acoustic guitar and the
fact that my my band has only heard the
song maybe twice in their whole life
they remember all of it you know and it
was just all those things where even
they were like you're crazy not to try
to record this Wow is there extra nerves
because you've been holding on to this
song for so long and you think it's such
a bit more nurse and finally putting out
there and hoping it's gonna be a hit um
no I think that any song that you try to
put out you're gonna have that same fee
right it doesn't matter how old it is or
hundred now the album is coming we know
is it completely done I've got one song
left to go report okay but it's
completely time to think you know
extending those four on yeah so is there
a chance to still go back and change all
I can do whatever I want up until you
don't you don't know when you're gonna
rule we're looking to release the album
in January okay so up until mid-november
in late November I can still make
changes and I'm constantly right or so
who knows what's gonna happen
yeah now nothing of this festival is the
merging artists showcase we have a lot
of artists that are trying to get their
big break like all other up-and-coming
artists to the track use this platform
to get a bigger voice out there what
advice would you have for artists
customers Carter's trying to get their
big bridge oh man
you know I'll be honest Graham I never
know how to answer that because
everybody's path is different for me
personally it was all about through
these years it's been about conviction
from day one to me that's the that's the
most important word are do you have
conviction in what you're doing and if
you're chasing something you know the
minute Sam hunt blew up he was doing
what he was doing his own thing and his
thing was different than anybody else
and he did it well right and then you
had 20 other people try to capture that
and they're still trying to do to me
that and then it's like well that's
already gone now and Sam can come back
and do it but the minute you're chasing
that regardless of if you know you might
get some fans for a little bit and there
might be a little bit of you know thing
around it because it's a thing in that
moment but the minute that thing is gone
only the guy that started it is going to
be able to continue work so my thing is
half conviction on what you're doing you
know be open to listen the people that
you trust but you have to stand firm in
your own convictions and that was how
I've always been I never let people sway
me and believe me there was so many
times where when certain trends were
happening I'd have my label send me
songs it sounded like there's trans
maybe like we need to hit maybe you
might want to do this I'm like hell no
I'm not doing it if it doesn't sit right
with me and if I'm not gonna enjoy
playing it and if I don't feel it when
I'm on stage then
essentially after a while they're not
gonna feed right and I always tell all
artists like are you gonna want to play
this on the 20 years is this song still
gonna be cool to sing in 20 years and I
think if you can say yes then you might
have something that's the thing is
they're a huge pressure to deliver hits
I just keep writing for sure I mean like
yeah I mean any time the jerd you get to
this level and you have a big record
label and you have a whole crew and you
have a team of writers and you have all
these people that are counting on you
heck yeah hits count I mean they they
matter because you know we've been kind
of one of those bands that has created
this very underground following we've
had our hits to help bring in other
people I'm always thankful when radio
does plants because it helps bring in a
new crop of people but then it's like
what can you do once they get in the
door and that's another thing from new
artists can you hold them do you have
enough meat right do you have enough of
that that that real stuff in your
catalogue that once you get them in the
door can you keep them there and I feel
like we've always been able to do that
yeah I know you got to go is there
anything that you do right before a show
like in terms of rituals or anything you
know man we we just we had the tightest
we're such a tight unit man and we all
just kind of hang out together for 30 45
minutes for the show we listen to music
we're all just it's kind of our moment
to be thankful of where we're at yes we
always do have a few drinks and that's
kind of our thing awesome I come out
here and I tell you that you get ready
to watch yeah yeah but you're gonna need
to